what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series today I'm going to be
reacting to I am this is this looks like
such a good video Brett Cooper
interviewing pro-life women or um maybe
this is pro-choice I don't know if this
is that she's at a pro-life or a
pro-choice rally but she's interviewing
them about men being pro-life um before
I start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that way you're gonna be notified of my
daily videos I'm excited I'm such a fan
of Brett Cooper I think she makes such
good content it'll be interesting
because I've only really seen her in
like commentary content that'll be
really interesting to see her in more of
like a debate style there's a life
involved which I'm assuming this is
we'll see right oh no this is pro-life
people okay life of the unborn baby so
no matter what you are no matter if
you're a man or a woman we are saving a
life when we stop these abortions life
is precious I mean to me it's like
everybody got support life because I
have a mother I was born I'm here and if
I wasn't if I was I would not be here so
it's everybody's job to help defend an
innocent person who can't hurt a soul
yeah hey y'all it is Brett from the
daily wire and today I am here in
Washington DC for the 2022 March for
Life we're gonna be going around and
talking to attendees about why it is so
important for men to be involved in the
pro-life movement so come along let's go
talk to some folks
so why are you here today well we're
here to speak up for those that are
voiceless The Unborn and are you a
father Yes I am father of sixth
grandfather of 20. wow
why are you pro-life it's important that
we protect those who don't have the
ability to speak for themselves I am
here to stand up for life and women's
rights I have always been pro-life
because I believe
um that everything I was kind of hoping
this was her at a pro-choice debate I
want us I want to see what Brett Cooper
is like in a debate I think she would I
think she would kill certain people it's
kind of ironic I use the word kill not
like that you know
um but but the one thing I was tweeting
you guys know me I'm always tweeting but
but I had a tweet the other day and one
girl was was talking about how men
um more men support abortion than don't
which I don't even know if that's true
or not but I I actually think we've kind
of conditioned men to think that they
don't have a say because it's in our
body and I I think the idea like Society
the idea of letting men know you do have
a say that is half your DNA that is
still your kid you should have a say in
abortion is unheard of like like they're
never most guys have never even heard
this so I think a lot of guys just know
they have no choice so they're just like
whatever what do you think King I'm
definitely pro-life though you're
pro-life well I I agree I think a lot of
guys Society has kind of stifled the
voices of men so it's almost like if you
go against what women want then you
don't really win in life yeah so it's
kind of like most people would rather
just succumb me I'm fine sleeping on a
mattress in a tiny room so I don't care
no one can control me no one can make me
do what I don't want to do what do you
think do you think that you could stay
with or do you think a guy could stay
with a woman if he she aborts this kid
if it wasn't his choice yeah now that
would be a simple I think that most
abortions are women in relationships
like if if we've had the discussion and
I don't want you to abort the child and
you want to abort the child then that's
the end of relationship what if she
didn't tell you so many women get them
they don't tell the guy well like if
sometimes I didn't know she was pregnant
yeah yeah they're not well I don't know
I don't know in it but yeah if I know
then yeah no I I'm saying like I think
it's really common for women to get
abortion to not tell yeah because I I've
even a couple girls that have come on
the show like that have had abortion
said it was from a guy and he didn't
even know they were pregnant especially
if if they're dating yeah she doesn't
like she doesn't want to end up with him
yeah because sometimes women date men
for money in it but like she probably
thinks like when she sees a better guy
she'll move but she could then fall be
pregnant in that period and then no
that's what I think it's like you know
it's funny they say fall pregnant it's
like a bad thing it's like if it's
someone in our language but it's funny
because I really think that if a woman
like women will keep a baby from a guy
they hooked up with one time
yet they will abort a child with a guy
they've been with for two years it's
like if you've been with him for two
years he's clearly not a bad guy
then they'll be like always
abusing
if Matters from conception until the
tomb I'm one of 15. I'm the 10th child I
could have been aborted you know without
life we have no other rights also I hate
okay I hate the argument that if they're
going to be poor they should be aborted
because now we're starting to get into
like rich life is now more valuable than
poor life and like the the rich kids are
for somehow more valuable and more
important than poor kids what what's it
called again Eugenics it's a Eugenics
argument they don't realize they're
making it because like again it's all
propaganda so it's like a lot of our
language that's why I always say like
this is feminism it's not to say that
like every person that uses feminist
language agrees with like feminism as a
whole but there's a lot of ways it's
like infiltrated into society the the
woman that started Planned Parenthood
isn't she one of like the founding
people of Eugenia yeah I know and she
had um
she had a project called the n-word
project and it was um it literally was
to de-populate like to eliminate people
with low IQ to eliminate um
African-Americans like they literally
it's all in her writings and it's crazy
because I know in New York more black
babies are aborted than born
and so you know how crazy would it be if
like a different let's take a different
group like Nike started right and Nike's
goal was to like somehow abuse like was
somehow had racist foundings people
would be boycotting Nike but for some
reason with Planned Parenthood it's like
their goal was racist and they're
achieving it because
um I don't think they're like I know
there's some stat like the black
population would be doubled today in the
U.S if it wasn't for Planned Parenthood
so it's like they're achieving it and
nobody cares it's literally eugenics
anytime we
take any human being and call them less
human or less than human it has never
worked out well for for society the
Bedrock of our civilization is whether a
human person has inviolable dignity and
that principle was undermined well it
was destroyed in Roe v Wade and so if we
don't defend that principle we won't
have any Liberties at all it's good that
we have all these young men out here I'm
an older guy but it's nice to see that
the
pro-life movement is getting younger and
younger each year
as young men
big part in the movement because
to make a child a man and woman issue
and men have just as equal right to have
the child as the woman does even though
it's in her body finally our generation
is waking up that true masculinity is
caring for those that are most
vulnerable and that starts in the womb
men are to protect life if we are
supposed to protect Society it starts
with life life is a foundation of a good
society and as men it's our duty to
protect that I think most men these days
think that since we're not carrying kids
or doing anything then we don't have
responsibility to be out looking over
seeing the welfare of what becomes the
future but posterity is really important
and there is no future unless we're
looking after those who come after us
and so what has happened is that is that
men have kind of you know they kind of
shrug and they say you know no I don't
really have a responsibility and that
hurts women the most men need to stand
up and they need to be the leaders and
if they're not willing to do that they
don't deserve to be called men really
when men choose to stand up and take
ownership and say hey I am here to
choose life too I am here to come
alongside and help support mothers in
their pregnancy and afterwards and help
with this child I think that's where you
start to see men really take a role of
masculinity and
um you ever notice how the only
masculinity and this isn't to pick on
her because I do I do sort of agree with
what she's saying but you ever notice
that um masculinity is only talked about
when it benefits women so like even her
like this is true masculinity to help
the mothers this is true masculinity to
like basically it's it's like once you
start noticing this stuff you can't
unnotice it let me listen to it again
choose to stand up and take ownership
and say hey I am here to choose life too
I am here to come alongside and help
support mothers in their pregnancy and
afterwards and help with this child I
think that's where you start to see men
really take a role of masculinity and
yes it's like when I'm going to help her
with this child but the crazy thing is
so what happened to all the masculinity
that they used to build everything
before the children came
it's only when the child is dying you're
taking care of each other you're
masculine well and even the leadership
parties they're talking about like
leading the family like it's so
interesting because they never and the
other thing they'll put is that a guy
can't be a high value man if he doesn't
have kids
like this this was a different
conversation but I've just been thinking
about this so essentially a guy cannot
be high value unless he succumbs to the
women's mating strategy but like there
are men like I think George Washington
didn't have kids I think um
Sir Isaac Newton like died a virgin and
those are men that are like still talked
about to this day so it's just
interesting how it's like whenever we
talk about the definition of like a real
man it's always goes back to helping the
women in some way I think my own
definition of high value of a high value
man is a man that can do a lot of things
I I don't think is it should be tied to
money or because I think you can be a
high value man and not be in the top
percentage of men when it comes to money
I really think so I think you could earn
like decent money and be a high value
man I think you have to be like having
influence if you don't have money yeah
yeah and I know because I'm thinking of
like Gandhi like is he a high value man
of course
yeah yeah but I don't think he has money
was kind of cool yeah like I think he he
lived on welfare yeah because the
reality is people make it sin obviously
we live in a in in the modern time where
it's almost like money is the only thing
that's important but the reality is
there are so many other things that are
just as important as money right but I
don't think you could say like Bill
Gates is in a higher because a lot of
guys are like kind of clown on Bill
Gates because he's like kind of out of
shape like I I don't think he's like
your textbook like Alpha dude but I
would still consider him high value
because he has so much influence power
yeah
um I think high value on Alpha two
different things yeah well that's the
other thing I didn't understand what
they meant because I would get offended
not offended but I would be like so
confused when the red pill guys would be
like oh yeah he's he might be Alpha at
work but he's not at home and I was
thinking well how could you say that
like this guy's doing [__] you guys have
never done but then what I realized is
like he's letting the women lead at home
and so you'll have men and even it's
crazy because it's even like church guys
where they'll say like my wife runs the
household your wife isn't supposed to
run the household that shows a lack of
leadership you know and then it's it's
interesting too because I've been
debating a lot with the track it's so
hard because I really would consider
like I really like the trade cons I just
disagree with them on like little little
things a lot of times when guys say my
wife runs the household it's like
imagine and I use a boss employee
relationship just to show like what if
you said like my secretary runs the
office
you know you wouldn't really say that
it'd be kind of odd you'd be like that's
a bit strange I I know like it can work
but it just kind of makes you look at
them a bit funny you know high value can
be separated into different forms so you
could be high value because you have a
lot of money and influence you could be
high value because depending on where
you are you're like probably really
strong
and oh yeah yeah and then you could be
high value because you're really smart
depending on where you are oh yeah
that's true I think Alpha is more
restricted to the Physical Realm no when
I think of alpha I don't even think of
muscles I think of like a guy that does
what he wants
regardless of like what everybody says
because you can all think of that Jack
dude that's such a [__] in his
relationship like she absolutely runs it
like I think of just like a a guy that
is like he lives his life like on his
terms now it's hard because then I start
thinking of the semantics I'm like well
if he's 300 pounds he probably can't so
I think Alpha is more tied to
survivability so you can live your life
on your terms and survive and thrive on
your own and even have other people join
you so like everything kind of ties to
each other but I think Alpha leans more
to physical and high value can lean to
either Financial or smart or strength or
whatever standing
unborn and
uh you say to your pro-abortion peers if
you could offer any wisdom or if you
could have a moment to talk to them what
would you say I would say
stop
go to church I would say think
critically about what you're holding I
think most people would say you don't
want to take innocent human life so if
you maintain that promise right but then
you say it's okay to kill a child who's
not born yet this is a contradiction of
terms all right follow the science
right everybody says he's the Christian
the right we're you know we're
anti-science we're just we're delusional
nah we're following the science and that
baby is a life I would say choosing life
is always the right choice there's a lot
of people looking for an adopted kid and
there's always a great family for that
child there's more resources than you
think there's plenty of people out there
who are trying to help sometimes it's
not well publicized so if you look
around you can probably find somebody
who can help with whatever problem it is
apparently there are awful lot of people
that are looking to adopt children now
it'd be nice if it could be a win-win
situation not a lose-lose I would like
to just tell those people to have that
unplanned pregnancy or just that there
are those people out there that'll help
you and I'm telling you it'll be the
greatest joy that you ever have bring
that child into this world and loving
them and I'll tell you A lot of times it
feels like it's it's just the end the
kid there can't be you know there's no
hope for me but when you bring that
child home and that child looks at you
and smiles them little ones I'll tell
you what what a joy it is in the heart
the best way another thing is I know so
many people that had unplanned
pregnancies that turned out amazing like
that we always talk about the horror
stories of like you know their lives
were over whatever but there's so many
people you know they used to have
shotgun weddings and made it work you
know the dad would get his shotgun and
say yeah you got to marry my daughter
now and they would figure out but
nowadays it's like we're so focused on
everything that could go wrong that we
don't talk about what could go right and
you never know like sometimes it could
be the best thing that ever happened to
you you um uphold a woman in in her
rights is to make sure that uh that she
knows that she's supported what is your
response to that no uterus no opinion
well well nowadays uh trans women are
women right and so what that means is
meant biological men are also women so I
think they've sort of uh left that one
uh out to hang and so because of that
but no and a more serious answer um men
don't have an opinion I think we have to
understand biology and that it takes two
to create a life and that's by God's
design and that's a beautiful thing as
young women why is it important to have
your male peers be involved in the
pro-life movement I think it's really
important that in this generation we
recognize that every man was once a baby
and as a former fetus they have a say
just as much as women do but we need the
support of men because they are the
father they are the brother they are the
son they are the friend we have that
phrase toxic masculinity and I think
that that is so detrimental because it
takes what manhood is supposed to be
standing up providing and protecting
wait wait wait they did it again guys
okay once you see this with the
conservatives okay whenever they talk
about masculinity it's always about how
it benefits women like they'll always
put like oh we need more masculine when
basically so we can have husbands for
the women toxic masculine
masculine told because it takes what
manhood is supposed to be standing up
providing and protecting see it's like
what is manhood supposed to be standing
up providing and protecting who does
that benefit women women and turns it
into something to be avoided something
bad and that's not at all how it was
created I'm looking around the crowd and
and again this is this is no hate no
hate I just it's just something like
once you notice it in the language you
just can't unsee it it's like whenever
we talk about masculinity it's always
how it can benefit women and I'll give
you guys an example if you say
um uh all right men make a lot of money
get good at talking to girls and be the
best version of yourself and when you're
done you can do what you want you can
screw a bunch of chicks you can get
married and it's so funny because the
Trad cons will come in and immediately
their gut reaction said no no no you
have to get married but if you really
wanted men to do what's best for
themselves that you would let them pick
let a man pick himself but you know it's
always and that's why red pill that's
why the red pillars get irritated
because a lot of them don't really tell
men like what they should do they say
get to this point so you have all of the
options so even even fresh and fit um
like Myron and them they they might tell
they tell a guy what to do to get to the
best position they can and have all of
the leverage what they don't do is say
go get married what they don't do is
they say um get in a long-term
relationship don't get married it's more
and even the screwing 50 Chicks that's a
lot of people get on them for that but
they say that because they're saying get
into a point where you have as much
leverage as possible you might disagree
with that but the my point is more they
push men to be the best version of
themselves
for themselves instead of for women post
Roe v Wade generation as everyone is
saying it so do you feel positive here
today is it uplifting it's very
uplifting I'm super excited I'm pumped I
love to see it you know these kids out
there and uh I can tell you for everyone
that's here there's probably 10 back
home I mean you look around here it's
all young people
you know this is what the
Spirit of America is it's about Liberty
for everyone well thankfully uh
president Trump uh put some people on
the court that are going to turn this
around and I think his legacy will be
life this movement is going to bring
America back because after Roe v Wade
it's going to continue and it's going to
be about making America great again and
I don't mean to say that in a political
sense with with Trump but really there
is a real need for the spirit of America
to rise again and the pro-life movement
is leading that that movement well and
we've told people for 50 years that we
can't be proud to be an American I think
that has been the most you know even
even being in London you meet so many
people that are just so proud of where
they're from
and like they they are so incredibly
proud like I'll meet someone from
Nigeria from Zimbabwe from Italy from
Spain from
um you know Poland like I I can think of
people that have been on the show from
all of those places and they all you can
just hear it in their voice there's a
sense of Pride being from where they're
from and for the past 50 years in
America we have told the American public
we cannot be proud to be American
um and you cannot be proud of where
you're from yeah it's a shame exciting
to see so many young people here every
year it's a younger crowd so I think
this is the the way for the future of
the life movement what are you looking
forward to if we get this overturned no
more people being killed genocide is a
massive genocide that's happened before
many of us were born so we are going to
protect each and every human being for
the for the future of our society and
that's that's the most important thing
that's why I'm here today so we're gonna
keep fighting for these babies and we're
gonna keep trying to overturn Roe v Wade
and get whatever we can to stop these
abortions hey Detroit Catholic Central
for pro-life baby
we have had an amazing morning here at
the 2022 March for Life in Washington DC
we talked to some incredible attendees
about why it is so important for men to
be pro-life for more information and
updates go to dailywire.com I'm Brett
Cooper thanks for watching
yes yes
such a Brett Cooper stand she seems like
such a sweetheart I do I am very
pro-life a lot of you may or may not
know I don't believe in abortion ever
and I really hate how a lot of the left
just tries to demonize the people that
believe in life as hating women
misogynistic and they try to Corner
abortion as a women's issue when it's 50
the men's DNA so if it's 50 through DNA
why don't they have a 50 equal say so
let me know what you guys think in the
comments um like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time